six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to the seven one nine area code
caller from seven one nine go ahead hey
david has done good how are you um so a
few weeks ago you were talking about why
you're not a socialist and you brought
up the Pareto principle and you said you
thought that was like a compelling you
know argument against socialism and I
wonder why you got that so let's to be
clear what what I said was that it's a
phenomena that can be observed in many
areas of human endeavors and I would
want a compelling case to be made as to
why it shouldn't be a consideration in
thinking about a socialist society sure
but I don't really see where this sort
of claims made by people who believe the
Pareto principle is some sort of law of
nature conflict with socialism
okay so socialism doesn't say that
people don't differ in their productive
capacity it just says that people
shouldn't necessarily differ in like you
know what they have as a result of it
right the problem you would very
differently the problem you would very
quickly run up against right is that if
indeed you were going to have that
differentiation in everything but the
outcome of what people end up with
you're you're going to be directly at
odds with that distribution like I don't
I don't know I agree with what you're
saying
in principle I just don't think it's an
argument for why we should ignore that
seemingly natural distribution in human
endeavors when it comes to how to
organize society in our economy well one
problem is that the Pareto principle
doesn't really indicate that people are
actually that vastly different
interrupted productive could have see
they might but this isn't really
something that we learn from the threat
Oh principles in the original sort of
discussions of the Pareto principle and
these new papers about it from like the
70s and 80s
yeah like the solar prize gesture was
mathematically like the proto printer
story like careto like distributions you
know right skewed distributions arise in
situations where there are some positive
feedback loops so in situations where
there's like uncontrolled positive
feedback loop cycle so money is
something like when you have money you
get more money when you have a lot of
citations on a paper you get more
citation as the paper is exponentially
better but because it
has just drawn more attention and it's
like a positive feedback loop you can
find example that we need just be
either-or I think I would never tell you
but just because there are examples
where you can identify a positive
feedback loop doesn't mean that one
exists in all cases so there are many of
examples where I I don't think that
there's actually a positive feedback
loop so but the fact that sometimes
there's a positive feedback loop I
wouldn't even try to deny because it
absolutely does exist but I don't know
what that tells us bigger picture of all
you're saying is that you know people
some people are more productive than
other people and they need to have like
a very robust incentive structure for
them to to be as productive as possible
that I would probably agree with but I
think that invoking the so-called Pareto
principle or 8020 rule here is kind of
pseudo-scientific
it doesn't really tell us anything that
you couldn't just say by saying you know
people are a little bit different I
don't think I agree I think that it
tells us more than just saying people
are a little bit different but I would
agree with you that it is not the be-all
end-all of figuring out how to arrange
an economy right so I think that it's
something that I mentioned in my piece
but it's not the foundation upon which
my entire worldview is based but I think
that it would be wrong to say it's
merely pseudoscience and it should be
totally ignored sure yeah I think it's a
bit of a pseudo scientific principle but
hey thank you for your fame I call all
right all right I just I just don't
think it's a pseudo scientific principle
I think we can find examples where it
may not be exactly illustrative of the
sort of underlying characteristic we're
trying to assess I don't know I don't
know if that conversation was remotely
interesting to the audience but I think
that that's pretty interesting stuff